en este vídeo vamos a hablar de los
poliedros poliedros un poliedro es una
figura en tres dimensiones donde todas
las caras son planas y todas las aristas
son rectas por ejemplo un cubo es un
poliedro
todas sus caras son planas son cuadrados
y sus aristas son rectas este de aquí es
un poliedro
una pirámide rectangular también es un
poliedro vamos a dibujarla en un color
diferente vamos a dibujar una pirámide
rectangular magenta y una vez más aquí
tenemos una cara rectangular plana y
después tenemos cuatro caras
triangulares planas esta de aquí es una
pirámide rectangular claramente se ve
como una pirámide pero porque se llama
pirámide rectangular bueno porque su
base es un rectángulo estos son algunos
ejemplos de poliedros o ahora bien de lo
que quiero que platiquemos es la idea de
desarrollo o red de poliedros déjame
puntear las demás aristas de este cubo
para que se aprecie mejor el poliedro
entero bien hablemos de desarrollo de
poliedros pero también se conoce como
red o desdobles que es un desarrollo de
poliedros
bueno podemos pensar en un desarrollo de
esta forma imagina que el poliedro está
hecho de cartulina y que vamos a
desdoblar lo de tal forma que obtengamos
una figura plana
ese es el desarrollo otra forma de
pensarlo es la siguiente si queremos
doblar una cartulina para crear estas
figuras como podríamos hacerlo para cada
uno de estos poliedros podemos crear
varios desarrollos distintos que
construyan esta figura en tres
dimensiones así que veamos un ejemplo y
tal vez el ejemplo más sencillo sea un
cubo como éste utilicemos colores
digamos que la base de este cubo es de
color verde así que podemos
representarla de esta forma esta es la
base del cubo en color verde
por otra parte digamos que esta cara
trasera del cubo es de color naranja así
que podemos representarla de esta forma
observamos que
estamos doblando la es decir la estamos
aplanando aquí tenemos la cara de color
naranja ahora esta otra cara trasera de
color amarillo podemos desdoblar la y
mantenerla conectada mediante esta
arista al aplanar la anp se va a ver así
y creo que ya tienes la idea general
para que quede muy claro esta arista que
tengo aquí
esta es la arista que tengo acá ahora
vamos a pensar en la cara superior del
cubo de color rosa
esta cara superior de color rosa debe de
estar conectada a una de estas caras
debemos conectarla a esta cara oa esta
otra vamos a unirla a stan si la
conectamos con esta arista amarilla que
tenemos aquí al desdoblar la cuando a
planeamos el cubo desdoblamos esta cara
amarilla y cuando desdoblamos la cara
rosa nos quedará am justo aquí aquí
tendremos la cara superior después
podemos desdoblar la cara frontal y
conectarla a esta arista nos quedará
justo aquí
y por último nos falta una cara del cubo
tenemos esta cara de aquí y aquí podemos
hacer varias cosas podremos desdoblar la
y conectarla a esta arista y entonces
tendremos que dibujar esta cara justo
aquí o si queremos hacer algo
interesante
podemos desdoblar la y conectarla a esta
otra arista la arista que comparte con
la cara amarilla es decir la cara de
atrás si la desdoblamos de esta forma
quedaría conectada a la cara amarilla y
la tendremos que dibujar justo aquí así
que podemos ver que hay muchas formas de
construir un desarrollo o dicho de otra
manera hay muchas formas de hacer un
desarrollo que cuando los dobles
obtengas este poliedro en este caso un
cubo bien hagamos otro ejemplo vamos a
trabajar con la pirámide rectangular ya
que este primer desarrollo sólo tiene
cuadrados todas sus caras son cuadrados
la forma más obvia de empezar este
segundo desarrollo es con la base que
tenemos aquí empecemos con la base y
después desdoblar hemos los diferentes
lados por ejemplo podemos tomar este
lado de aquí y desdoblar lo y entonces
se va a ver así
podemos tomar este otro lado de aquí
atrás desdoblarlo y entonces se va a ver
así bien después podemos tomar esta cara
de adelante y desdoblar la conectada a
esta arista y se va a ver de esta forma
y finalmente podemos tener esta cara de
color verde
una vez más desdoblar la sobre esta
arista y quedaría por aquí
ahora bien este no es el único
desarrollo para esta pirámide triangular
existen otras opciones por ejemplo
podemos explorar una de ellas en lugar
de conectar la cara de color verde de
esta forma podemos desdoblar la sobre
esta otra arista que la conecta con la
cara azul podemos ver esta arista vamos
a colorear la esta es la arista del
triángulo azul y vamos a dibujarla
entonces cuando desdoblamos la cara de
color verde sobre esta arista se va a
ver de esta forma
muy bien espero que esto te dé una idea
de que existen varias formas distintas
de desdoblar esta figura de tres
dimensiones este poliedro o dicho de
otra manera hay muchas formas distintas
de recortar una cartulina y doblarla
para construir estos poliedros a las
versiones planas de los poliedros o
dicho de otra manera a estos poliedros
desdoblados se les llama desarrollos